So one of the topics we're covering in this course
is Memoization or caching,
writing down values that we've already computed
so that we can be lazy and not have to recompute them later.
We've used this as one implementation of parsing
but in the Real World, it might come up in many other places.
Brendan, have you had a chance to use it at Mozilla
or in your other projects?
Not so much in parsing because we are in a tight competitive regime
with other browsers, and you have to parse very efficiently and lex very efficiently.
But in building a browser, you end up memoizing or caching a lot.
You end up trying to remember decisions you made
that were expensive, that can be preserved under some rules and reused.
We also have a memory management system that's quite complex.
We have a garbage collector for JavaScript,
we have a reference counting system for our C++ code.
The two have to meet, and it's possible to form cycles,
which then have to be collected.
We use an old David Bacon data programming trick.
It's Bacon and Rajan PLDI 2001, I think.
It's a cycle collector for reference code objects,
and it buffers pointers that it suspects of forming cycles.
And a pointer, in a reference kind of graph, can form a cycle.
Every reference count is going down, from above 2 to 1 or above
so that you may still have a stuck reference there, due to a circle.
And so we use these techniques.
We constrain a little bit in using C++
that has to run on Windows, Mac, and Linux.
But in Python and JavaScript, people memoize all the time.
And there's a craze now for PEGs--
Parser Expression Grammars?
I think that's the acronym; I always mix it up with something else.
But it's a parsing technique that can use memoization
when it's backtracking
and accord it Choice, so
we're familiar with this, and we try to use memoization to a good effect.
At Mozilla we have less use in parsing--more runtime, I'd say.